the Marvel Cinematic Universe grows just
a little bit bigger and hugely a whole
lot weirder with every new movie and TV
show that slides in front of our
eyeballs when the original Iron Man came
out back in 2008 the world he lived in
seems pretty grounded in reality the
strangest thing that could possibly
happen in that film was a rich guy
deciding to build himself a suit of
armor in a cave to become an
international vigilante then fight
another rich guy in some other armor who
wanted to be an even worse international
vigilante that's pretty strange but not
out of the realm of possibility right
we're still waiting for Elon Musk and
Mark Zuckerberg to throw down and
televise the whole thing on Facebook
life but since then we've seen God's
monsters whole other planets whole other
dimensions and all sorts of magical
hijinks and fold in ways that could make
any same person's head spin so how has
the MCU kept feeling as real and fun as
ever well former Marvel Studios had a
visual development Charlie when has some
ideas on that the man in charge of just
about all of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe designs over the past decade
sat for an exclusive interview with us
to talk about how and why I am man was
actually the perfect superhero to
kickstart the MCU as we know it what was
good with Iron Man is that it laid a
foundation for what is tech on earth how
do we ground it to earth and to things
that we understand Tech is something
easier for us to sort of you know we use
it every day right he explained the iron
man's connection with technology is a
convenient starting point for audiences
to find the connection with a world that
looks a lot like our own but is also
full of super people but helpful
Foundation revealed that despite iron
man's than reputation as a lower tier
comic-book character he was the perfect
choice to kick off Marvel Studios
cinematic ambitions most people would
have thought like why why are you
choosing a character that is sort of
just a kind of a B character in Marvel
Comics world but you know I think that
was a smart move but technology isn't
the only reason Iron Man was such a
strong choice for Marvel's first film in
a shared cinematic universe even though
we all use phones and computers every
day very few movie goers are also
jet-setting billionaires
that's why Iron Man's alter-ego Tony
Stark and the fact that Robert Downey
jr. played him was
other crucial piece of the puzzle to
help audiences connect with the film as
well as the wild it shows on screen so
it was great getting Iron Man situated
and then having Robert Downey in that
role it was you know it was amazing he
kind of is that character it's all the
flaws that he sort of just puts out
there right how do you make that
character and that world more relatable
and less scary it's not a Superman
character where it feels maybe too
perfect and too alienating and hard for
people to resonate with that somebody
with lots of flaws not all of us have
the same kind of flaws that Iron Man did
our Tony Stark but I think you know it's
so obvious that it makes it safe for
anybody to approach once I am an
established a baseline of the MCU is
reality
the studio could start to explore bigger
weirder ideas the next logical step of
course was to try to get as weird as
possible as quickly as possible
Marvel Studios third movie was 2011
store which happened to be the first
film Charlie when worked on at the
company as the head of design when
you're trying to write some kind of
story paint an image one of the things
that you do first is you figure out what
your limits are the farthest you're
gonna go where are you gonna start with
and so it's your contrast what is your
contrast that philosophy determining the
contrast was an approach when used while
designing all of the MCU movies he
worked on like guardians of the galaxy
characters Gomorrah and Drax the
destroyer as it turns out Marvel Studios
itself wound up doing just that by
releasing Iron Man and Thor so close to
each other since they're literally
worlds apart that was the big thing
about laying out Iron Man and Thor is
one of the biggest contrasts that we
could find and could this still work
because if this can work there's a lot
of play in the middle check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more exclusive looper videos with
Charlie when about the creation of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]